one of the biggest mistakes is people
rush into something and they get a
little desperate for something and then
they overpay you're going to either make
or lose most of your money when you
first acquire the property the other is
some people will be like yeah I want to
have multiple houses and they have
properties that are sitting vacant year
round you're just wasting money on that
property if you have a property either
be making an income off of it or be
using it regularly like an example is if
you if you're you know the market
crashes and people sort of like lose
their shirt with their house because it
lost value and they had to sell that's
that's where you could lose but in
reality in a market like that the rental
market is very very strong and so there
are other ways to utilize uh where the
market is to make sure you're not what
happens when mortgage rates go up fewer
people get mortgages they can't afford
mortgages when rent when mortgage uh
costs go up more people shift to renting
so there's the only people who lose
money are the people who freak out and
sell or the people who freak out because
they're going to lose property and
overpay do you guys ever consider doing
like infomercials like like that and
motivational speaking about Finance
economics and how to make money I've
been talking about setting up a Proto
booth and just lecturing people on the
street about all the stupid real estate
decisions that they been making what but
I but do you I I don't think that's a
crazy idea and thank you for uh plugging
the Proto Booth but but what I'm saying
is there is value in you know uh one of
my favorite books I ever read uh was
Rich Dad Poor Dad did you guys ever so
so it was about how and I don't have a
GED but it was it was it made making
money in real estate kind of simple yeah
I just think there's a huge market for
that and I think you guys need one more
show where it's just about you know Q&A
just you wait yeah you just wait are you
doing that wink okay people who are
making bad decisions in real estate and
just need to be you know yeah bailed out
somehow but it's true I mean in reality
not everybody has what it takes to
become wealthy in real estate not
everybody has you don't think so no
because my I believe they do that's
what's the Rich Dad Poor Dad but even
even when you read Rich Dad Poor Dad you
realize somebody has to have the
discipline to actually follow through on
certain things have the discipline to
you know not waste money on a lifestyle
that's not going to get you anywhere not
everybody has that discipline if
somebody is willing to actually do what
it takes anybody could do it anybody
could be successful in real estate so
it's just a willingness to do it pretty
much there a lot of people don't have
the discipline well exactly it's not
just the willingness it's it's the
ability to um put aside any like people
will make their impulse buys like
everybody in the the American way is to
overspend and buy frivolous things that
you don't really need so if you can
discipline yourself but there's also in
Rich Dad Poor Dad I mean they talk about
ways of putting as soon as you get your
check put some of the money aside and
pay down certain certain debts and then
um think ahead that's the kind of stuff
if you can get in the habit of doing
it's great because then you're you're
stopping yourself from even taking
advantage of that money our very first
investment we were 18 years old we were
actually leasing a property right next
to the University of Calgary and we
actually we were squatting on the lease
because they had students had been
coming and going from this place for
like 20 years the rent hadn't been
raised in like 10 years it was I think
it was 800 bucks a month and there were
five bedrooms in there we actually
illegally finished two more bedrooms in
the basement so we just like framed up
walls and put in beds and we so now
there were seven students sharing we
didn't own the place so everything was
done just sort of you know temporary but
we ended up making enough money on this
shared accommodation that that was our
down payment on our first place that we
bought and then that first place we
rented it did a shared accommodation
there which paid all of our expenses for
the next year we then took that money
and bought another place and that's how
it all started so instead of us going
out and overspending on our own rental
we were okay compromising and doing a
shared accommodation and the one thing I
would say in the early days one of the
lessons that we learned was we were
always looking for a quick Buck we were
looking for a quick flip and we did do a
lot of flip properties back before it
was popular but when I look back now if
I was more disciplined if Jonathan was
more disciplined we would have actually
held on to more of those Investments
because what th those would have been
worth as rental properties or whatever
now it would have been ridiculous we've
still done well with what we've grown
but it it's a matter of that discipline
so I I think if you don't have to sell
don't sell right is a exactly like what
why would you it's like buying a stock
do you buy high and sell low no terrible
idea so the only reason you would need
to sell unless you're shorting
true uh the only reason you would need
to sell is uh you know if if you're
desperate for the money so the other
thing you can do which is how a lot of
people you know buy real estate is
they'll they'll loan against the asset
they do have to get another asset which
can also be a good thing because it can
make it so that you have the cash you
need to do something else but you don't
have to dispose of the existing one the
downside is if there's a complete market
crash that's when you had all these
people who wanted to be real estate
Moguls and they lost their shirt because
they overleveraged so one piece of
advice right now with with with the way
the Market's heading I I would just say
you need to sit down and take the time
to Define what your goal is if you know
what you want down the road then you can
build a path towards that whether it is
holding property whether it is flipping
whatever it is that you want to do if
you know that path you can see it and
you can follow it slow and steady if
you're just guessing like I want to be
rich okay you're not you have nothing
laid out to get there so how are you
going to get there yeah for me I'd say
um be every every dollar counts you know
so this is not just in your real estate
but in your lifestyle too but also in
the maintenance of your home there's so
many things you can do that will prolong
the life of your asset um and if you
don't do those things inevitably it's
going to be 10 times the cost to repair
something down the road so understand
how to properly maintain if you can if
you're getting a property if you can get
a property that is maybe a little bit
more than you need but if you know
you're going to have a family if you
know you're expanding don't set yourself
up to have to sell and buy another place
right away because that's where where
you lose all the money to legal fees
real estate commissions um accounting
fees get a place that you can grow into
cuz the long it we tried to make so much
money in quick flips we did dozens and
dozens of flips when we were younger and
we would make like 30 grand a flip but
we had all the risk one guy came in and
he bought 10 of our properties from us
and all he did is hold on to them for a
few years and he turned around and made
a clean million dollars off of the
appreciation the long-term play in real
estate is is always more successful than
the quick flip so that's the goal try
not to buy sell Buy sell get something
that you can hold on to I love that do
you guys have you ever invested in
short-term rentals do you play the
short-term rental game or not really
yeah we we don't do a lot personally but
C and we have I've done a little bit of
it and actually my wife and I had a
property in Pasadena that we were going
to build out to be shortterm but we've
just we've changed our plan with what we
want to do with that too same thing more
I you know building long-term rental
portfolio you know it's exciting to
think that you can make more money on
short terms but it's a heck of a lot
more work as well and also in California
is tough because there's so many
restrictions with um you know rental
restrictions and and what you and also
uh one thing to keep in mind with any
rentals always think about you have to
be comfortable with some vacancy some
people are not comfortable with vacancy
they get desperate and they'll put
somebody in who they're like uh should I
and it turns out that this person
destroys the place so you have to be
okay with a little vacancy to get a good
tenant
he